[Musica]
parto con una domanda come vi sentite
quando fate qualcosa di buono per
qualcuno come vi sentite quando qualcuno
vi dice grazie
oppure vi confessa che quello che avete
fatto per lui o per lei ha cambiato la
vita è stato davvero importante mi
sorride ma con tutti i denti che a chi
in questi casi si sente bene a quanti
denti che vedo è sì fare del bene ci fa
stare bene e lo abbiamo visto anche con
gli speaker di prima ci rende più felici
ci rende più forti a non solo ci rende
anche più belli o un amico che abita a
san francisco è che non è molto attento
alla manutenzione della sua auto nel
senso che guida fa benzina ea volte
manda anche la moglie non ci va nemmeno
lui ma stop però organizza e pianifica
dei viaggi meravigliosi quest'estate
cosa è successo aggancia la roulotte
alla propria auto e parte per una super
vacanza nel sud della california
dopo circa un migliaio sì forse un
centinaio di miglia non di più lo ferma
la polizia stradale è signore avete la
luce di posizione sinistra che non
funziona ah sì l'amico scende va a
verificare e scoppia in un pianto a
dirotto disperato signore non faccia
così cioè non è tanto grave
ho perso la roulotte
ecco il più delle volte perdiamo la rule
o del bene per strada e non perché siamo
cattivi
no è che proprio tendiamo a non fare il
bene degli altri
tendiamo a fare il nostro bene personale
il nostro interesse personale questa era
la brutta notizia ma ce n'è una bella
accidenti ciascuno di noi può allenarsi
per diventare una brava persona
quindi da perfetta schiappa etica
ciascuno può diventare un super atleta
già da dire è semplice da fare meno
perché abbiamo a che fare con delle
brutte bestie che sono le nostre
abitudini tutti maestri di tutte le
tradizioni spirituali del mondo ci hanno
messo in guardia dagli effetti delle
abitudini
sto parlando delle abitudini cattive
naturalmente perché perché le abitudini
incidono un solco nella nostra mente
dove il pensiero e di conseguenza le
nostre azioni
girano e girano e girano più e più volte
ecco dobbiamo cercare di fare qualcosa
e qui entra in campo l'etica dobbiamo
cercare di trasformare l'etica in una
buona abitudine e guardate un'esperienza
di tutti cioè non c'è cosa che non venga
resa più semplice dalla costanza dalla
familiarità dall'allenamento magari lo
abbiamo verificato tutti io all'inizio
quando ho cominciato a guidare ero una
frana
ero timorosa titubante e pasticciona
facevo un sacco di casino bene adesso
per lavoro faccio tanti chilometri la
settimana sono diventato una leclerc in
gonnella becco anche molte multe per
eccesso di velocità
però ho imparato a guidare devo dire
molto bene quindi cerchiamo di allenarci
come fare in modo che l'etica diventi
una buona abitudine mettendola in azione
mettendola in pratica
e guardate questo è un elemento davvero
tanto importante sono i nostri
comportamenti arrenderci chi siamo non
le nostre idee non i nostri principi per
nobili che siano e quindi cerchiamo di
allenare anche l'etica attraverso delle
azioni concrete
certo
l'allenamento è una cosa dura ragazzi
non è uno scherzo e fatica e sudore e
tempo e costanza e umiltà ma ne vale la
pena
di recente leggevo che il pugile cassius
clay mohammed ali diceva sempre odiato
ogni singolo minuto dei miei allenamenti
però mi dicevo tieni duro
soffri ora ma diventerai un grande
campione e di fatto è andata proprio
così in concreto che cosa fare allora
individuiamo una cattiva abitudine che
proprio vorremmo risolvere
lo so lo so ciascuno di noi ha una lista
lunghissima di abitudini che vorrebbe
cancellare scegliamo n'è una prendiamoci
un obiettivo etico in relazione a quella
cattiva abitudine ad esempio abbiamo la
cattiva abitudine di non ascoltare la
persona con cui stiamo parlando
ecco sviluppare l'ascolto è porsi un
obiettivo etico
analizziamo la situazione che abbiamo di
fronte proprio come un chirurgo
cerchiamo di circoscrivere la situazione
cerchiamo di capire bene cosa sta
succedendo quando tendiamo ad avere
questa cattiva abitudine con chi
soprattutto perché secondo noi ci viene
da metterla in pratica quella cattiva
abitudine a questo punto decidiamo quali
azioni determinanti ossia in grado di
determinare un effetto quindi incisive
rispetto alla realtà
noi potremmo compiere e scegliamo n'è
una
ma non la più difficile scegliamo la più
piccola la più semplice quella che ci
costa fatica ma non una sfacchinata
pazzesca
stabiliamo tempi e modalità di feedback
eh si questo è il piatto forte del
nostro allenamento etico abbiamo visto
che i muscoli dell'etica solo come i
muscoli del nostro corpo diventano più
forti più tonici più resistenti se li
teniamo in allenamento
allora diciamoci quando metterò in atto
questa azione determinante e in che modo
ne terrò traccia ipotizziamo che è
andata bene abbiamo compiuto la nostra
azione
a questo punto può essere l'occasione
per valutarsi in modo sincero ma senza
menarcela troppo insomma senza a
giudicarci in modo aspro come mi sono
sentito in questa azione
se la rifacessi che cosa cambierei e
quale aspetto di me mi rende soddisfatto
mi fa dire bravo papà che cosa ho
appreso per il mio sviluppo etico
dall'aver compiuto quest'azione ok
magari non l'abbiamo compiuta come mi
sento per non averla compiuta
che cosa mi ha ostacolato dal compierla
anch'io sono una gattara è assolutamente
però rispondere
dovevo accarezzare il gatto non è una
risposta valida che cosa potrebbe
stimolarmi a compierla questa azione
ancora una volta che cosa ho appreso dal
non averla compiuta
insomma bisogna passare dai principi
alle azioni l'etica è più figlia
dell'esperienza che della conoscenza o
della sapienza bisognerebbe tornare al
significato originario del termine etica
che deriva da un vocabolo greco ethos
ethos in greco significa va proprio
comportamento usanza costume abitudine
l'abbiamo detto prima ma lo ripeto sono
i nostri comportamenti che ci rendono le
persone che siamo non le idee
possiamo avere delle nobili idee magari
non abbiamo mai perso un file dei fori
futures ottimo ma se poi a casa non
riusciamo a fare una buona raccolta
differenziata non abbiamo compiuto
alcuna azione determinante e non
possiamo certo dirci amici dell'ambiente
cosa potrebbe aiutarci in questo
allenamento etico bene tenere una scheda
di allenamento giornaliero
esattamente come facciamo quando andiamo
in palestra dove teniamo traccia dei
progressi che di volta in volta
noi facciamo è molto utile tenere una
scheda è perché ci permette di capire
anzitutto quale cattive abitudini noi
vorremmo affrontare ci dà informazioni
su di noi ci permette di conoscerci
meglio e ci dà più motivazione a
cambiare verso il positivo se ci
spezziamo regolarmente evitiamo di
essere etici solo a principi solo a
parole solo a idee
ricordate la storia del mio amico
pianifica viaggi meravigliosi ma poi non
aggancia correttamente la roulotte
all'auto qualche suggerimento in
chiusura
impostiamo l'allenamento in base a chi
vogliamo diventare beh certo poniamoci
un obiettivo
all'inizio non esageriamo cerchiamo di
costruire i nostri muscoli etici a poco
a poco se ci poniamo come modello san
francesco d'assisi
come inizio auguri alleniamoci con
qualcun'altro coinvolgiamo in questo
allenamento etico un familiare un amico
un collega è molto più motivante
ma ma non confrontiamoci con gli altri
ciascuno di noi all'inizio è stato un
principiante probabilmente anche cassius
clay all'inizio le buscava non le dava
alleniamoci ogni giorno per avere dei
risultati concreti
l'allenamento etico non può diventare
una cosa che facciamo una volta all'anno
perché se è il fioretto fatto in
quaresima
andiamo poco lontano mangiamo del buon
cibo mentale certo nutriamoci di idee
che ci rafforzano nutriamoci di daddy
bene e lo abbiamo sentito prima il bene
genera altro bene quindi no a patatine
no a caramelle e non troviamo scuse per
rimandare l'allenamento
io odio lo sport in tutte le sue forme
da bambina i miei genitori volevano
farmi diventare una campionessa in ogni
sport e quando per esempio io dovevo
andare a tennis
di solito la prima lezione l'avevo di
lunedì io cominciavo già il sabato ad
annunciare solennemente ai miei genitori
che probabilmente probabilmente lunedì
avrò la tosse e forse anche raffreddore
forse mi viene la febbre anzi mi viene a
broncopolmonite un vecchio proverbio id
dice che le cattive abitudini sono più
facili da abbandonare oggi che domani
quindi direi di metterci subito al
lavoro
quindi stasera oltre a ri ascoltarci
quella pietra miliare dei velvet
underground and nico oltre a fare lo
abbiamo sentito prima una meditazione
sull'autoironia
proviamo a fare questo esercizio di
allenamento etico e mi raccomando non
perdiamo la roulotte
[Applauso]